now eight news now is learning more  about vaccine distribution  efforts nevada congresswoman suzy lee  hosted a public forum  on facebook with health district chief  health officer dr fermin leguin  dr lewin talked about current locations  where the vaccine is already being  administered  like western high and unlv school of  medicine but by the end of the week  the county will open cashmen as a mega  site  administering three to four thousand  doses a day  we are not certain yet what will be the  achievement of vaccine from from the  federal government so  right now what we know from the state  immunization authorities in nevada is  that a  nevada is is receiving about  35 000 doses of vaccine per week  that would that won't be enough for a  our needs well the health district is  also planning another mega center at the  las vegas convention center  that could open in a few weeks offering  4 000 vaccines  a day